[Music]
hey there I am Bryan Douglas and I am
here in my garage to talk to you about
the jam stack and how to make Jam sack
websites so before we jump right in and
I tell you how to build a jam sack app I
want to actually show you what actually
building so what we're looking at here
is this a simple restaurant website that
has the basics of what you would see in
a restaurant one being in a menu so
we've got a basic menu here you can see
different types of menu we got a lunch
we've got a dinner section we've got
prices on the right very fancy that's
why we don't see any dollar symbols
that's how you know how upscale this
restaurant is in addition that we've got
a drinks menu which you can see here as
well as a simple about page so I'll just
simple routings if you're very familiar
with like modern web technologies and
frameworks routings always built in so
we're talked about how to do that in the
jam and then in addition to that we've
got a simple gallery where we can show
off some different images and then
finally we'll have a forum where you can
actually submit reservations now we're
gonna move over to showing you how to
clone this site as well as talking more
about what Jam stack is so I'm gonna
give you a one-time gift and that's
pretty much all of the code and for this
repository now if you look in the
description of this video there's a link
and if you click that you'll be able to
clone a version of this tasty tutorial
you can also visit bit ly slash taste
the tutorial either those two links will
actually take you to this page which is
gonna be a wizard on net LeFay com
granting access to your github account
will allow you to create a new
repository based on the template that I
provided
here you can change the name or you can
leave it as the same since I already
have a version of this already saved I'm
gonna head go ahead and change the name
and once you click Save and deploy it
will then bring you to a screen where it
starts to build your site for you
so once your site's built you'll see a
screen just like this which is an
elephant and here you can see one thing
I want to point out which is the URL of
where your repository was created it's
gonna be your github account that you
connected to net with five and I'm just
gonna go ahead and tell you to go ahead
and click that link and it should open a
github repo with that code this is a
repository that includes all the code
you need but also includes a readme with
more instructions on how to get this
started
so if you get stuck at any time you can
actually check out my repository at
github that calms class-b Dougie slash
he go restaurant tutorial here you'll
see the same code that you see in the
repo that you you cloned except that now
we'll have some branches where you can
actually see the solutions to you each
step so if you do get stuck all the
codes gonna be available here for you to
look at so feel free to leverage this if
you if you aren't able to follow along
or if there's an error that you cannot
get past so that you have your own
version you just want to go ahead and
clone this repo
a repo URL and calling it on the command
line
you
now once that's done you can go into
your repository and as outlined in the
readme you wanted to do two things
MPM install
and then finally MPM and start running
npm start with this go ahead and compile
everything into a bundle and load your
very own version of tasty licks freeze
view this tutorial is actually based on
the static site generator you go in
based on statistics from static gem calm
Hugo is the second most popular static
site in ER and it actually has a pretty
strong engineering culture and community
around it supporting it
now this tutorial also will be based on
Hugo but it's gonna be based on a Hugo
boilerplate that also adds an asset
pipelines so if you're familiar with
either the rails asset pipeline or
you're comfortable with NPM and node
packages you will find yourself right at
home with this sexy dinner which is
Victor Hugo which adds NPM post CSS and
a bit of web pack to your pipeline to be
able to manage dependencies
now once you have cloned the restaurant
template that will be focused on you
will need this install Hugo and if you
are on a Mac you can do that by brew
install Hugo and if you down on the Mac
you can visit the Hugo installing guide
to find out how to install he go either
on Linux or Windows systems as well now
if you get stuck installing kedo please
feel free to check out the the forums
for he go which will be discoursed go he
go dot io here is a pretty thriving
community that will actually be more
than happy to help an assist on getting
your environment set up as well you can
also reach out to me directly or check
out in the comments of this video so i
mentioned earlier in this video that i
was going to explain what the jam stack
is and i'm gonna go ahead and default to
a jam tech org already says jam sec is
this a way to describe modern web
development architectures where it's
based on client side JavaScript and then
reusable api's and all that information
can be found more about the jam stack
from Jam Network where we actually have
different examples as well as some
resources too if you're interested in
finding out more about use cases and how
other people are contributing to the jam
architecture but I do want to take a
chance to explain a little more in depth
of how they got here
and so basically what we're looking at
here is just this normal website
architecture so we have a client and
then you have a server and that server
usually is not as simple as what what we
see more the server normally looks like
more of like a monolithic application
structure so not only behavior what you
see on the browser which is the client
but underneath under the hood you have
like a web server an app server API
server as well as like a database and
because of that all that content
actually walks around with you whenever
you go to host or deploy your site to
the web so people can actually view it
and I always like to use this this
analogy of monolithic architecture is
like this
so back in the day when I was a kid
which actually still sold us in the
actual stores but they have the idea of
putting peanut butter and jelly in the
same jar this was actually pretty cool
when I was a kid but it at the end of
the day it didn't work out very well
because sometimes you only want jelly
and sometimes you only want peanut
butter but in this instance you have to
take both of them in one big scoop so
when you go to the ploy a monolithic
architecture site you have to deploy
everything all together so then you have
all these one-click solutions that have
done really well but we found out really
quickly those who have become really
expensive so pushing the analogy even
further I'm separating the two ideas of
api's our backends to separate that from
your Friday which is your client so in
essence this is what the Jam is all
about separating your client from your
API are your front end from your back
end and what's really made this real
easy from modern sites that are built on
JavaScript or even other language is
that we've had a lot and Sergent of all
these javascript build tools so we had
grunt goal browserify NPM now it's kind
of take it over as far as the scripting
build tool of choice and then also web
pack as well
all these build tools are making easy
for us to bundle our JavaScript node
apps and there's something that can
actually be hosted easily through static
which brings me to the static site
generator so now we're getting more of
surges and Static generators back in the
day we only had a handful now we have
tons as we saw earlier in static gen
calm hugo is number two but number one
is jekyll and then Gatsby and middleman
are both very very popular in the space
as well as a whole slew of other ones
and what they do is they take what we're
very used to having the command line
interfaces in the interactions and build
sites really quickly but we could also
take that that complicated setup and
then bundle that into a static output so
we have an index.html that can be hosted
easily on a CDN on multiple servers on
the web without the heavy weight of a
database or our back-end following it
around
instead we we would talk to an API
directly to gather our data all that to
be said is that the site that we're
building is gonna have a pre build
structure so we are going to do
complicated things we are going to talk
to micro services and third parties
solutions to do some of these nice
features that we want in our restaurant
app but we'd have a the idea of a pre
build structure so every time we push to
get we get the idea of having continuous
delivery and it goes straight to our CDN
which for this example it's gonna be
nullify so we can continue to push on a
regular basis and update and see those
updates happen live without the need of
keeping our database in sync or keeping
our app server and sync at all the whole
purpose of this video series is actually
to show you how you can build modern
websites and web apps on a structure
where there's not actually a strong tie
to backends and databases so I hope you
enjoy and I hope you got a better
understanding of what the Jam stack
architecture is
kyouko and other static site owners for
the most part use markdown as the basics
for rendering dynamic content on the
page with this project nothing's really
different we have a menu that lists a
bunch of food items and we want to
render that same counter on our page the
problem at the moment is that our
version of site does not have any sort
of menu whatsoever so I can't go to
slash food
and see any food items because we
haven't set that up yet so we're gonna
go ahead and do that now and I'll be the
first thing we'll tackle and if you
haven't gone to the readme yet you will
need to NPM install so once you've
installed the packages using NPM you go
ahead and run NPM start to actually run
a live version of your site to view now
we're using a tool called browser thing
so it should open up the browser for you
and you should see the live site ready
to go so open up your text editor and
find you could find that this the the
structure of the code is actually laid
out pretty nicely
the project itself most of what we're
gonna be doing is actually going to be
in the site folder that's gonna be our
content for food in etc the source
folder is gonna have your CSS your
JavaScript images and the the main video
that you see on the back of the home
page that's gonna be living here
images are ready to be set up here and
for the most part the CSS is a right
delft or already done for you so you
don't need to actually do any CSS in
this tutorial so the config tamil is a
place to tap into the menu system that
we want to add to now if you're
unfamiliar tamil tamil stands for Tom's
obvious markup language it was created
by the creator of jekyll another static
site generator that's very useful all
you need to know is that our menu is
gonna be updated here so what I want to
do is create a new route so I'm just
gonna copy exactly what we already have
here and I'm gonna go ahead and make
sure that this weight is too so that way
I'll have the about link but also have a
link for our food route since I have
this live updating in the background we
can now see that we have food working as
a route but when I go to this route
nothing renders and the problem is we
don't have anything in the food content
structure
so if I go back to our code I'll need to
actually go into our site directory and
I'll need to go into content and then
here we'll need to create one folder and
may call it food so I am personally
using vim so I can do this straight from
my VIP meta if you're using atom or
sublime or something similar like Visual
Studio code just go ahead and create a
folder and this directory called food
now that I have a food directory I can
now create my first food item
now each item in the in the the content
structure is gonna be a markdown file
and there's this concept within set
excite generation which is called front
manner and in this front manner we can
actually denote details like date
different things like categories which I
want to distinguish this to be lunch and
also have different types like roles all
this information is gonna be available
to you in the the actual description of
the video so if you do want to copy and
paste that feel free if you want to
switch things up also feel free to do
that but I'm gonna go ahead and save our
content as is just by filling out this
frontmatter and between the the triple
dashes we should be good to go to see
our first food item available for us to
view so if I now click food I realize I
still don't see anything and that's
because I'll need to update our static
site generator to understand that
there's some changes available so I just
went ahead and killed a server and I'm
gonna restart that for us so we can now
see our first food item available for us
now go ahead and go back through this
and see if you can now add a couple more
food items so instead of just lunch I
would go ahead and add some dinner items
as well in addition you could also
create some different unique choices and
descriptions and pricing so take a crack
at it at that and I will show you how to
make this process of adding new food
items much easier using a content
management system which is going to be
our CMS in our next video
so adding the ability to update food on
the menu dynamically was pretty
straightforward but maintaining updates
to the menu probably get pretty tedious
as you probably have discovered first
hand so thinking of a head chef or a
kitchen manager and it needs to make
updates under the menu on a daily basis
they would need to either clone the
repository locally or login to github to
make changes and chances of that
actually happening on a customer's end
is properly pretty slim so with the
current state of the project all changes
have to grow through a web developer so
there's a lot of solutions to handle
management of contents and since we're
already on the net laughs I trained and
deploying our site there I'm going to
recommend us use identify CMS to get to
CMS connected you'll have to do just a
couple things
inside your project folder really need
to go to site and then the static folder
and inside here you'll need to add a new
folder which we'll call be called admin
once you create a new admin folder you
want to create two new files and that'll
be the kick fig gamal which is gonna be
different than our config that Tamil
file for Hugo this config that ya Milles
gonna be very specific to the CMS and
then you also want to add an index.html
the contents of the config dot yeah Mel
and the index.html are both available
here under the net off ID documentation
under the QuickStart tab and then under
configuration now that we have the
index.html I want you to first copy over
the contents from the documentation into
here so that way it looks for like so
I'm back in the config that um I'll
break the sound line by a line so this
llamo file actually look very similar
than what's in the example and the
documentation with some changes but why
my line I'm gonna break it down like so
here is a section that's to tell us what
back in we want to use by default
Delphi CMS works with github
out-of-the-box we're actively working in
other solutions but for now we're gonna
use github and I'm gonna point it to my
repository which is gonna be my name
slash the name of my repo it also wants
to know what the base branch is gonna be
now the CMS will work on any branch that
you choose here so you would you want to
check to see you whatever branch you
want your live code to go to so this
could be any like demo or staging my
preferences master I'm gonna set this to
be master here now the media folder
we're gonna use for a future video but
we're gonna set this now just in
preparation because the CMS requires you
set a meter folder for any images that
you want to save through the CMS and
since I already know I may use that I'm
gonna set it for that and then finally
we're gonna add collections now each
collection is actually separated with
this - and so I can have future
collections hinton we could also have
like a drink menu or we can have some
sort of dessert menu as well but for now
we're gonna have a
all food menu and we're gonna set these
labels now these labels are not gonna be
set outside of the CMS you won't see the
item you won't see the label food item
outside the CMS but this is for the CMS
to be able to present it visually and if
you also know site content food is where
we saved all our previous food items
with their detailed frontmatter and this
gives us rights to be able to save and
then finally looking here these fields
here all mimic exactly what we have in
our front manner so these fields are
looking directly at that front of matter
and being able to save and one thing to
note as well is that for supported meals
we've got two default options one being
lunch the other one being dinner and
this is gonna be based on a widget so
widgets are something you can look up
and that will actually get in more
detailed in a future video but this note
that widgets are different types so we
do have a widget for string list and
text so those are the three ones we're
to be using for now so I'm gonna show
you exactly what the frontmatter looks
like today which here for our oysters we
do have date which we're actually
ignoring in the CMS though it is
something that does get saved every time
I markdown file gets saved but you can
also note that we do have categories for
lunch and dinner
we do have types which type is here
but the label is here and I'll show you
what that looks like in a moment but for
now go ahead and commit your changes to
CMS so go ahead and pause the video make
sure you have you config that matches
pretty close to what I have here and
commit that to your master branch and
I'll meet you back in a few seconds at
the net nullify dashboard now back at my
net will fly dashboard I can now visit
the access tab to add an install
provider we can do that from our github
profile by going to our profile picture
up there clicking settings and down here
it says ooo applications you want to
register a new application
now I already done so here which is
providing me a client ID and a secret a
client secret now be careful not to
share these secrets
but go ahead and take that client ID and
bring that back to nullify now back at
the dashboard I can now install my
provider based on my client ID in my
secret
and now back on my live site instead of
adding all my content locally within my
text editor I can actually now go to
slash admin log in via github
and I can view my CMS a CMS to be able
to edit the food menu is great but it's
almost pretty limited to only have a
food menu now based on everything we've
done so far
adding the food menu to the CMS I want
you to go ahead do the same thing by
adding a collection to your config that
yamo as well as adding a new link for
drinks and I want you to add all this
content dynamically through just using
the CMS now if you get stuck on doing
this feel free to look back at your
config that ya mole in your CMS but also
leveraged the net lo-fi CMS get our
community who are ready and willing to
help anybody who's looking for help with
the CMS once you figure that I'll see
you in the next video and we'll look at
the code now you should have your CMS
that looks like this it has food arms
but also drink items available to look
at and edit and if you took some time to
add some different drink items you would
have them look like this which is very
much similar to what we have already in
our CMS now you config that yeah mol
would only need one more collection that
copies exactly what we have in our food
structure in addition that you did want
to go
I didn't go to your site and you can fig
that top tunnel to make sure you added
drinks to the menu so that way you
actually do see it any menu when you go
to your site live
that's it hopefully you were able to get
through that if you weren't let us know
if there's anything edge cases also
continue to hang out in the Gator
community for any questions and concerns
and help of your project so when looking
for a restaurant to eat at it's always
nice to look at pictures of food as well
as what the place actually looks like to
get kind of a sense of quality and if
you can't even like it so having some
images somewhere is actually ideal for
our restaurant site and which is what I
have here so as you can see so as you
can see I have a carousel that I can
cycle through and see different images
of the restaurant and food and then it
cycles back to the front and I also want
to point out in the layouts folder we've
already been using a structure to render
our content but I didn't really talk too
much about how this works and what
didn't you go we do have a base layout
that loads our index page and this is
where we see our video but we also have
a default layout structure which lists
all of our content so in he go they have
the idea of categories and each of these
categories are separated by sections as
well now consider sections being what we
how we outlined our content and the
config that yamo so each section being
food drinks and also one that we haven't
talked about yet which is the about page
each one of these sections are being
separated by a conditional so if we
happen to be on that that particular
conditional that is the section that
we'll be displaying and we're doing this
logic by just doing this here this
conditional within this block so Hugo
uses a go template rendering engine is
which is what we see within these
handlebars or if you may the curly
braces now I wanted to point that out
because
we're doing one more thing for images
which we actually I already give you the
code here so you don't have to actually
add the carousel directly the page when
we add our first image it will actually
automatically do this but I don't want
this to seem like magic so I just wanted
to point this out here's how images are
being displayed on the page and above is
how food and drinks are being stencil it
on the page so if you have any questions
about how this works or how Hugo renders
templates please check out the Hugo
documentation on taxonomy x' as well as
listing and displaying data with that
being said what's going to add some
images first thing we want to do is go
ahead and add a folder within our
content structure called gallery now if
you remember we have the config Gamal as
well within the CMS architecture and
here we can actually add another
collection called gallery and here we'll
have a label called Geller image and
it'll make sure the look in the folder
site content galleries so everything
pretty much is straightforward as we've
done before except for one thing
if you check out here and our our field
type we're using a widget called image
and this is because we're no longer just
gonna have static text to add to upload
an image we're actually gonna upload an
image in the CMS using their CMS image
widget and since we've added a gallery
to our CMS you can now see that we have
a new item in our sidebar called gallery
images
and here you could either use the file
uploader to upload image or you can drag
the image directly onto the image widget
and now you have an image and now I can
click Save and see that wive on my say
my site so now when I visit tasty Delphi
comm I'm able to visit my gallery and
see that my image is already there so
does one more thing we haven't done yet
to make this restaurant app fully
functional to the way I think it should
be and that's actually adding
reservations now we created this form or
I provided this form rather as part of
the template so I should be able to
submit my name my email and when I would
like to show up at a restaurant from my
reservation and because it's a slash
contact I already know that in slash
contact there's going to be a route
ready and available for me which is why
I'm going to the pages and then contact
a folder so that I'm in the contact
fault the contact markdown file I now
notice that I have a regular HTML form
ready for me to update it's also got
some of the same markdown that we see on
the page as well now you can see the
only thing I've added is the net off ID
tag name all I need to do now is save
that push that back up to github which
will then trigger a new deploy on notify
and I'll be right at this submit forms
so now once I go ahead and fill out my
information and hit submit
it's back on my dashboard I'll go back
to the site dashboard for form handling
now this feature is incredibly useful
but it can actually be even more useful
if you check out the notified
documentation that will fire also has a
cool feature which adds notifications to
form interactions so every time a form
submission happens you can send an email
notification as well or you can send a
slack of notification and if you already
have some sort of web hook existing you
could also add a web hook to either
notify through a database or through
some sort of lambda function as well so
spend some time seeing how to integrate
your form notifications with the form
that we've just created totally hope you
enjoyed going through this little
project of mine creating this restaurant
app I encourage you to take this same
template and see if you can build
another restaurant app build of
different CSS our different styling go
to restaurants in the area and see if
you can apply the same sort of template
to local restaurants and see if they can
use a modern site without the native
servers and be able to host that for
free using a tool like nullify